JOHNSON, SENATOR FROM WISCONSIN.
YOU HAD A TIGHT RACE YOURSELF.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS, I THINK
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
ASK THEMSELVES, YOU WERE IN A
TIGHT RACE.
SEEMS REPUBLICANS, RELUCTANT.
RESISTANT TO EARLY VOTING OR
VOTING BY MAIL.
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THE CASE IN
FLORIDA REPUBLICANS VOTE BY
MAIL.
DO VOTE EARLY.
MY QUESTION IS IF THAT IS TA
CURRENT SYSTEM, DEMOCRATS RUN UP
BIG LEADS BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
REPUBLICANS WILL BE PLAYING
CATCH UP.
>> WE HAVE TO GET BETTER AT IT,
SEAN.
>> YOU HAVE SEEN A COUNTY MAP OF
THE UNITED STATES ALL -- EVERY
STATE SAME WAY.
WISCONSIN BLUE AREAS DANE
COUNTY, MILWAUKEE COUNTY,
MADISON.
DEMOCRATS HAVE A LOT LESS
GEOGRAPHY TO COVER.
GET THOSE EARLY VOTES OUT.
WE HAVE TO MINE VOTES EVERY AREA
OF THE STATE.
SAME IN GEORGIA.
IT IS MORE DIFFICULT TASK.
WE NEED TO DEVOTE MORE
RESOURCES.
FEWS LESS DOLLARS SPENT ON ADS.
AD SPENDING IS GROTESQUE.
THEORY OF DIMINISHING RETURNS.
WE NEED TO ALLOCATE MORE MONEY
TO THE GROUND GAME.
WE HAVE TO MINE VOTES FROM AIL
OVER THE STATE.
HOW THE FBI ON A WEEKLY BASIS
WARNING BIG TECH COMPANIES.
I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE A
LOT MORE WHISTLE BLOWERS.
FBI MEETING WEEKLY, ALL THESE
BIG TECH COMPANIES, WARNING THEM
OF HACK AND LEAK OPERATION,
FORMER HEAD OF SIGHT INTEGRITY
FOR TWITTER, YOLE ROTH TESTIFIED
UNDER OATH, FBI MENTIONED YOU
MIGHT GET INFORMATION ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN.
YET WE KNOW FBI HAD HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAPTOP FOR 20 MONTHS AND
PLENTY OF TIME TO VET IT TO FIND
OUT IT WAS IN FACT HIS LAPTOP.
WHY WOULD FBI BE WARNING BIG
TECH COMPANIES, THAT THAT WAS
HUNTER'S LAPTOP.
DID THE FBI PUT THE FINGER ON
THE SCALE LIKE THEY DID IN 2016
TO HELP A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
>> THEY DID.
BRIEFING OF FBI 2006.
FBI KNEW CHUCK GRASSLY WAS
INVESTIGATING BIDEN.
THERE MIGHT BE HACKING GOING ON
HERE OF CANDIDATES, FAMILY
MEMBERS.
THEY COULD TAKE THAT HACK
MATERIAL AND TURN INTO
DISINFORMATION.
PEOPLE LIKE ON HUB.
THEY WERE SETTING THE STAGE,
THEY KNEW HUNTER BIDEN COMPUTERS
OUT THERE.
THEY THREATENED AND AVEILED WAY
MR. MCISAAC.
DON'T GET IN TROUBLE.
DON'T GET HURT.
WHAT WAS THEIR COORDINATION WITH
THE 50 INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS?
THIS CONSTRUCTION OCCURRING ALL
THROUGH 2020.
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS ALSO
TRYING TO DO ANYTHING TO
UNDERMINE SENATOR GRASSLY'S AND
MY EFFORTS.
SEEMS COORDINATED EFFORT.
FBI.
MAIN STREAM MEDIA AND SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES.
>> IF YOU USE THE WORDS OF ELON
MUSK.
VERY DEFINITION OF YOU SHUTTING
DOWN DECENTING VOICE ES IT IS
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
FBI WARNING THEM HACK AND LEAK
OPERATIONS.
YOU HAVE TO BE ON THE LOOKOUT.
DID THEY NOT KNOW NOW THEY HAVE
HAD IT THREE YEARS.
SHOULDN'T THEY HAVE KNOWN.
WHY WOULD THEY KNOWINGLY BE
LYING TO BIG TECH COMPANIES.
>> IN THE 2020 ELECTION.
GIVING ME THAT BRIEFING AUGUST
THEN LEAKING IT AND SMEARING MAY
2021.
>> Sean: RON JOHNSON, GOING